DO YOURS.HAT WAS DRRLS .
. NY POWERFUL.
IT WAS IMPTA MEENGDAY IN THOSE
TH W
WAS DECIDINGOW MUCH OF THE
TRUTH I WANTEDEX AND TO Y.
T T WAS
BEUS B THAT
VISUAL IMAGE COULD YOU ACTY
OPLE TO UNDERSTA TGRAVITY OF WHT
AND HOW MUCH WT CO DEVASL RTR T
SH SAY MUCH OF THEO
ATE TRUT>> THAT THESE WEAPONS
CAUSDS THAT ARE WA
WOUNDS, THE IN SEE O, THINGS TH
, MUCH LESS ANY
OR IS EVER RDY TO SEE.RCED INTO.
YOUTEIMLEADING WITH THEICIANSRE
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE
HAPPEN?
>> AT THVERY LEAST -- I DON'T
O USWO GUN CONTROL REFORM.
ST IMPLEMENTINTYFETY
GUNS CAN'T
AT SHOULDN'T HAVE THEM, THAT, K
IEYFFER FNESS OR
ANY OTHER IONAL .YOU GET DIAGNO?
BUY OR PURCHASE VE SOME KIND OFL
ISSUE THATLD CSETO PERFORE
GOOD
START>> YOU S A THEAY
THE SHOOTING.
YOU'VE KNOWN HER SIN S W.L US AA
MOMENT THAT YOU SAR AND HER
., AS I WASTO THE HOSPITAL, AS S
THE FIRST -- FIRSTF
PATIENTS TI  IKETO THE ER.
SHE WAS BLNG
SHE WAS OBVIOUSLY
CRYING, SHA BLEEDINGSHOU.ULD TE
SHRAPNEL WOUNDS ALL OVER HER
BODY.
E HAD BLOO
D  IS, HAVSEEN M
SINCE SHE N MIA
MONTHS OLDAND I IMMEDIATELY TOE
YEAH, I THINK I JUSTR
MOM -- YOUR MOE AS I
OUT, I DID THAT SHE WASY.
ITRIFYING TO SEE
ICALLY LIKE
BECAUSM
FOR SO LONG BE IAT SITUATION
FORGET WHAT YOU SAW THAT DAY
THE BLOON OTHES THEY WERE WEARI.
DO YOU THINK IS LE FORCROSS THEO
E HORROR O YOU SAW?
>>
I K UNSSAND
YOU FELTT ANU STILL FEEL
ITE COMMUN TODAYS STL MOURNING
STILL AT THIPOINT, YOU'LVER TRU
MEALE
HORRENDOUS ACTS, THISH
I THINATTA
>> IT'S BACK TAT INITIAL .
POINT YOU MADE, UTH YOU WANT
PEOP
ATD TO KNOW?
WHATO  NEE
TIN, I KNOW IT'S HARD FOR, BUT
THAT TDO YEAH, I JUST INORTA
NEED TO KNOW THAF
KNOW, ES AND WOUNDS THAT TY THE
HESE TYPES O
THE REPORTS ARE OUT  WW THAT DA
EVERYONE'S SEEN MY TESTIMONY.
THAT'SETNOILY
UNR
N. A IW YOU'RE A
PEDIATRICIAN.
YOU T  Y'VED
THINN E.T OWE  N
SEEN ANYTHINLIKE THIS.
>> HRE YOU?
HOW IS YOUR COMMUNITDOIN
WE'RE BROKING.
YOOW AGEDY AND HERE I AM SPEAKI
TO YOU, HE IM ATHE.
CAPITOL.
MOAGO, I WASOW
NORMAL AILM OF IL
TASK.
I NEVER THOUGHT THAT IG HERE WI
PE WHAT'
HAPPENO .
TODA AD A MEETIN
TH SOME POLICYRS JUSSPEAKIF